yeah how you doing Josh good to see you
it's great to see you guys I was just I
just showed you a picture the guy that
created this song rod Simba rod
Cymbeline your music producer for The
Sims and left go podcast rock and The
Sims 2 from Texas man that's awesome
where do you get this brought some butt
from Texas I think he lives in Texas
he's a Cowboys fan cool one of my best
friends in college was rod who are the
other people in Texas history that have
worn to anybody
I only the great Eric Metcalf right
that's a cool it was great that was my
homie yeah well the best kick returner
Power Turner's have all done Yeah right
so yeah he's he's definitely one of the
famous twos after that there's not
anybody so I didn't get it to my senior
year what were you before that of what I
were ain't my freshman year that's so
funny my number is actually I to go one
in one my sophomore junior which I
really did not like one I really didn't
why because it's just one number it is I
just didn't want to be like bats well
numbers were one and three three cuz
Iverson won because I just like the look
it looks good yeah but I did it I like
single digits I wanted that right and 11
was taken by major right he stole
Ricky's number after Ricky went from 11
to 34 his senior year he will be Ricky
was 11 his freshman so entire college
player numbers too though no they do
Ricky's is retired
Syracuse like thorough girls retired
were it's like very special recruits
right right no yet Ricky's retired Earl
Campbell's retired Vince Young's retired
I think Colt McCoy might even be retired
something like that but it's deservedly
so yeah he had an awesome career I
believe yes he did hi Josh what's going
on
how you guys feeling today you want to
talk about yes you're good I feel really
good to talk about yesterday what time
do you sleep till today I woke up at
like honestly probably about 8:50 Wow
yes you've slept in a while man it was
amazing yeah my kids slept in that was
the biggest thing okay they said I let
him stay up late last night because you
know we were in LA all that stuff right
you know yeah I let my kid pay for
tonight to like 10:30 and then he watch
Saturday at he's he's literally
out of the room some days and I go have
you been in there I want to be like have
you been in there doing crack all day
cuz you coming out his hairs everywhere
in his eyes like and I'm like damn have
you been on a crack binge here was he
fighting like it's scary
did he win or was he just yells he's got
his microphone with his ear thing sound
like this he looks like he's a head
coach of a football team I was like look
at this mini does he sound like a head
coach he sounds like me I mean this is
what I'm getting a like my wife as I
give he sounds like you used to when you
were playing Madden and yelling at 12
year olds and telling how crappy they
were has he had an insult that's
actually made you laugh yet oh he says a
lot of stuff yeah he really does he's
come up with he's learned a lot more
trash talking oh no today boy it's funny
because you've kept technology away from
yes old school I told them last night I
was like this shit's about to change
whoa look rules are coming I was like
schools come in you ain't doing this
[ __ ] during the week we're going back to
weekend's oh I mean that's how I go look
at this
you're [ __ ] crying yes over a video
game that's how crazy it's making you
I remember one F word I'm trying to do
one F word this podcast I remember I so
I used to play Madden all the time yeah
and I would play until like 6:00 in the
morning when I said like I was top 20
online for a little bit like I would go
and I would talk all the trash on that
and I remember that most of my losses
were late at night and my mom would just
come in and rip because I would do the
Internet cord from like three rooms down
my hallway and it would just reach the
Xbox and she would just come down and
pull it out at like 4:00 in the morning
and I reacted like Philip you need to
pull it away yeah now he's got two more
because so two more weeks of summer get
him in the program who's still eating
burps like what did you eat today that
you're like oh I don't know I mean I'm
just worried about your digestive system
now it's top notch
it's probably just it's the coffee I've
had coffee and okay I had a coffee right
before we started that's all it is I'm
looking out for you like friends Rick
was looking out for me on Mondays
podcaster Joe
he said don't yet good juju got the
shirt good juju for juju Smith I'm the
Oracle of the week at least he said
don't say who were interviewing when
stay well it didn't happened I had the
worst travel day in the history of man
yeah take his throat I I don't really
want to could have been the best day had
it ended the way we thought it I just
sat on a plane for three hours the mill
the rainstorm and they're like alright
we're actually gonna fly and then the
pilot comes out two minutes later goes
I'm actually in overtime so like it's
illegal for me to fly so everyone get
off the plane so then I go home and then
oh we're gonna get a charter plane to go
to Pittsburgh and I was like okay so I
take an uber an hour up to Westchester
and then as soon as I pull in Josh
called me and goes oh we're not gonna
get it and then so I drove an hour back
yesterday was like the worst day of my
life yeah I'm sorry I know you got all
thrown onto you I mean I went to the
airport I hung out when I got
rescheduled for the nine o'clock flight
I said I'm going home I have no faith
that this flight will take off because
they were coming over the like saying
that the federal government had shut
things down and when I heard that I was
like man this doesn't sound good
are we allowed to say what we were going
to do uh yeah yeah go for it
we are gonna work out with James
Harrison and we still are gonna get
reschedule Ordnung right oh man it's
gonna be awful it's gonna be for the
change is gonna be awesome but you
actually got to like hang out with him
yes so we were at the gym check and josh
is the only one that actually hated that
yeah I was there with the crew we were
at the gym just checking it out figuring
out where we were gonna do all the stuff
with him and when we got there it was
just the manager of the gym and James's
rep and then we're standing on this
balcony overlooking the gym and I feel
something tapped me on the shoulder
someone tapped me on the shoulder and I
turned around and there's James Harrison
t-shirt shorts flip-flops break it down
hang out at the gym big big guy
generally I mean not tall not tall but
the thickest individual maybe you've
ever seen in your life I texted you guys
that I thought that his chest
front-to-back was two of me smashed
together
I'd say Jim said three yeah and yeah I
would smash it the density of it that's
what you have to saw he'd have to smash
three of you together a little very big
head right real arms how big of his head
cuz Sims has a big head yeah definitely
football player definitely bigger than
your hand there's no sort of reason that
they can throw their heads around but
abandon and like you got thick skulls
big oval head and arms to just I'm
famous for my hard head in the house New
Jersey you're famous
for your heart head I mean people always
like my family especially they literally
laugh at me they think I have like the
hardest head in the world like when they
grab my head or give me noogies or when
I used to be like that drunk high school
college kid who like oh you want to get
in a head-butting contest sure let's do
it what like yeah stupid meathead [ __ ] I
wasn't sure what a drunk high school
college kid is yeah I guess so was he
funny was he scary he was not scary at
all he was actually super nice and he he
was down to t talked to all of us and he
answered all of our questions and was it
like a private gym no he works out in
like a public gym in this suburb about
30 miles outside of Pittsburgh so when I
see James Harrison with like chains and
stuff there's other so he's got two gyms
he's got the Arizona gym and the
Pittsburgh gym I don't know I'm excited
to work out with him but I'm scared to
death I don't know what the Arizona gym
is like but the Pittsburgh gym he's just
there with other people just random
Joe's Joe's there was gonna be a
basketball game of just random guys
going on in the background while he does
his workout man and he what we were
talking about he was like oh yeah I'm
just gonna make them do everything that
I do and that'll be yeah that's how
we'll do it
then it was just completely
matter-of-fact no questions asked okay
great see you guys 4:30 in the morning
do you yeah
4:30 well he starts at 5:00 so he gets
there at 4:30 Godley I need to do a
thorough warm-up before we start that I
just hope he doesn't warm up to it okay
good all right so we got a lot on this
show I saw some people a little upset
that we only got in two quarterbacks on
the last episode but that was the theme
of the show right but Sims has given me
seven guys that we're gonna get to a
more in depth scouting report of just
some other guys that Sims loved before
the draft I also have just some random
news I got some videos to go over and
then God bless Jalen Ramsey did an
interview with GQ and he pretty much
commented on 2/3 of the quarterback to
the NFL we're gonna run through them and
Simms I just want your raw reactions I
agreed with a lot of them I think he
actually agreed with us too
right but I'm excited to get to them we
have Phil coming on so it's a good
episode it is it should be good yeah
I've got some you know the this this
time of the year week 1 pre season 2 we
just I'm evaluating players there's
nothing scheme wise it'll get go
oh wow they're they've changed their
defense they're not gonna do that on
week one of the preseason but yeah
valuating players would certainly have a
few it's funny as you go through the
list of how many you haven't been
playing how much of the first rounders
have been banged up a little bit I've
done nothing yet to this point I'm just
looking at all the first-round running
backs Rashad Penny broken fingers Darius
guys we know about but like there's so
many guys that are injured right now
yeah I know
and no more we haven't seen Marcus
Davenport no Vitae via yet right
so no gir Alexander yet all those guys
so I'm excited to see if they play this
week but regardless it was fun looking
and I looked at pretty much most of the
first round except there's some of the
old linemen that I didn't get yet but I
think we're gonna get all the sexy names
out of the bargain so let's do some
videos and just your reaction to them
first okay first one up this one was all
over the place yesterday deejay swear
injure terrelle pryor working out with
his former team and every time he went
and touched the ball the washington team
was freaking out right this was the play
though that got a lot of attention swear
injure comes up to Terrell Pryor after
the play and just absolutely Punk's him
so he goes and pretend his throw a punch
at Terrelle Pryor and terrelle pryor
like with the ultimate flinch I don't
know what he did to them last year he
must have talked way too much crap and
practice and pissed off that whole
defense now he can be that way he can be
a real stubborn tough I don't give a
damn what you thinking because remember
when he left the team was like a wait
until you're on the other side so that's
what I would guess happen I would think
that there was a lot of tension between
him and the defense all year last year
and then when you don't perform right he
had some drops that all that he had the
injury right so that does just DB's they
just want to eat that up few things if
you think you're gonna get in a fight
with somebody yeah remember that you're
wearing a helmet and even if they're
gonna throw a punch it doesn't really
matter yeah do you believe that
flinching is challenge of your manhood
no I do now I mean who cares I mean he
flinched he might have flinched and came
back and thrown a right hook and you
think I was gonna flinch who care like
Kobe but yeah it doesn't mean in the
only thing I look at it that is where
the hell the Jets players to defend them
a little bit because there's like 20
[ __ ] guys going there so when I just
see things like
I don't know this but it just goes man
maybe the Jets aren't really backing him
yet either they don't know him don't
like him enough to do that those are the
little things I look at
also DJ smear injure I mean he's the
leader of the defense that's the one
thing I just continue to see reading
between the lines
talking to the DeAngelo Hall who talks
about it a little bit when we were with
you what'd he say to you he just said
swear injure is holds everybody
accountable meetings everything and he
remembered some of the comments last
year he seemed and said I feel like some
of our guys aren't going all in every
week it's like that yeah I mean I
respect him for that and he of course he
is no-nonsense physical type of football
player who I really think would pay
money to fight terrelle pryor right
there in person if somebody kind of like
tried to Punk you like that are you
allowed to just punch them in the face
like who's there's this thing right but
he does this and then you flip how it
goes all like your rules are off he
could have gone into a fight you could
have absolutely stopped me nobody would
have been mad at him right the problem
is is Todd Bowles we've met him because
right now apparently terrelle pryor
doesn't even have a friendship yeah with
Todd bolt right you've opened up a whole
new thing to look at for me with your
stuff about how the sidelines react to
things that happen like I said about
Josh Allen the other day bills going
crazy and now how they the judge reacted
you hear those little things right yeah
I feel like that's something I want to
watch now as I do yeah so apparently
terrelle pryor came out and revealed
that he's recovering from a broken ankle
that happened in an offseason may work
out Todd Bowles really didn't like that
and said I feel like he should keep his
mouth shut and leave the injuries to me
I'm actually on the side of terrelle
pryor here somewhat terrelle pryor has
not been out there has not looked that
great and I can imagine as a player I
would have a hard time being told that
you're not performing well and you know
that your ankles broken s but the team
is not telling anybody that your ankle
was broken I get it too
why would the team not admit this I I
honestly like I understand hiding
injuries during the season and things
like that
but yes I don't understand why Todd
Bowles would be so angered at this point
there's no game there's no injury report
we know he had an injury last year and
that's why he didn't perform
why is he not been taking as many reps
they've been telling us he's on our rep
count
every day right oh yes he's letting you
know I don't underst I understand if
Todd Bowles got mad and this came up in
week two or week three
because then teams go oh there's
something wrong with his ankle so he
might not be good at cutting off that or
doing this route or whatever it may be
but we still have plenty of time before
we get to that point so I did think that
was a hair of an overreaction kind of
felt we're like but what I my antennas
are up with I only like your antenna my
antennas my antennas are up with like
connecting our last story so there's
Todd Bowles I don't see Jets players
over there to defend them I'm just
saying he might not be loved with the
team right now I could be wrong but
those are the things I am going to be
watching closely here for the next few
weeks I also look at it and just watch
some of the Jets games Jermaine Kearse
looks like he's gonna be a factor yet
again yeah I'm excited for Quincy and
noon wanna get back Robbie Anderson's a
player yeah they're not weak at this
position it's actually become a quiet
strength of this team
I agreed I'm a hole I'm gonna pull up
there Rob and also the Alabama kid yeah
I mean exactly all right Darius
Stewart's in there you know I knew that
like suspensions and off the field stuff
like Terrell priors fighting for a
roster spot yes and that I mean they
have good tight end play I think that's
something that's not being talked about
with the Jets are one of my teams that I
really want to say will be fighting for
a wild-card spot right because I look at
the team and I go I love James Boettcher
I love what he can do with that defense
yeah I mean they almost threw away they
did throw away like five games last year
I mean they were certainly competitive
and a whole lot of good a whole lot of
games I look at that and I felt like a
lot didn't go their way I can see that
flipping this year I agree and remember
how I look at how the the lines changed
they were one of those teams whose line
drastically changed I could see them you
know fighting for a seven a nine eight
and eight there's no superstar front
seven difference-maker secondary could
help out the secondary is solid you do
have the sharper Ron Lee sorry I was
gonna call him sharper for summers
around Lee at linebacker they don't like
pass rusher like Lorenzo Mauldin to get
back to what we thought right big and
physical and there's no game that
they're gonna go onto the field with any
team in football and they're gonna be
overmatched I think that's what your
point is and what probably my point is
with the Jets - well that's one
and bully them but don't you think
having James Boettcher allows you to
maybe not need a pass rusher because of
how he creatively plaits is live Jenna
Jets yes but he's on the Giants James
Boettcher no I'm having fun
yeah you could correct me the first time
I don't think I even heard you say it
the first time yeah it is very similar
and I think that sometimes why'd the
pass rushers not valued in that scheme
as much just because he goes we're
blitzberg and we can find creative ways
to do that because that's it's the
blitzberg scheme alright so here is
another video again if you're watching
us on youtube in the bleacher report
channel I will put this over but this is
Vernon Davis talking to Zach Brown and
kind of make it a little bet do you
think that you can do the alphabet
backwards right now no way Josh do you
think zy x 2 bv u TS r q pn o m LJ k h
ID f e d c ba I [ __ ] up in them I mean
you definitely [ __ ] up I don't know I
couldn't even tell the presence but TS r
QP n om l KJ h g no I just wanted to
show off weird you know why I used to do
this or something I did it on purpose
because for a long time I I was like god
forbid I'm ever pulled over by the cops
and I've had alcohol if I can remember
and guys do not drink a drive if I can
remember do the alphabet backwards I'm
gonna get out of it that was like in my
mind what I thought I could do I just
didn't put myself in that situation I
wouldn't recommend anybody but when I
saw this I was like you I want to get
$10,000 I would $10,000 I'd probably I
would study hard to learn it further
than a night if you said ok you're gonna
give me $10,000 okay I have no dad I
could do it tomorrow
yeah for sure I agree with you I don't
know if I can do it by tomorrow because
Zach Browns definitely not coming I
wouldn't think so middle linebackers
yeah I'd have a hard time believing he's
gonna pull that one out of his butt in
like 24 hours oh no disrespect no
disrespect but the middle linebackers
I've been
yes I would say that not big backwards
alphabet I would say none no no all
right so one last video but I quickly
Hard Knocks came out Tuesday night I
know I'm seen yeah Corey Coleman I
thought was interesting he like went in
there and actually requested a trade in
a way before he got traded I don't think
he requested but he went in there and he
said why am i running with the twos if
you don't want me then trade me right
and then it was like Cory Coleman's been
traded is that how quickly it can happen
it can especially if it's a guy where
they're just going we're not sure about
you many ways and then we know we're not
sure about you you haven't proven
anything to us and now you're talking
about this and you don't even have the
right to come in here and talk about
that yes you just go talk to Todd right
so there you go
he's interesting yes so he didn't want
to deal that probably pissed him off
that was his way of like yeah I've just
crossed you off the list basically and
I'm sure they've read the team meeting
later that and I are coaches meaning and
they talk about it and they go you know
where they evaluate his character
whatever it's been the injuries all that
and they go you know let's just move on
the can Tonio callaway weihnachten know
when to hold them when Antonio Callaway
got arrested he didn't tell anybody on
the Browns yeah and that entire practice
all the coaches like what's wrong with
you like you don't have focus and he
like didn't tell them I just thought it
was funny that episode one Hugh Jackson
told all the coaches we're gonna make
sure our guys are healthy and then
episode two they play Antonio Callaway
every single snap and work him into the
ground yeah like what like where's the
consistency no and I don't work you know
giving him every snap and working him in
the ground to me is all about they're
just trying to make sure he's in shape
after he gets suspended the first week
or one or two don't tell me it was
punishment like yeah it's punishment for
the player the player the ballers they
want to be on the side hanging out and
meaningless football games it's like a
status check right so he didn't get to
do that so I understand maybe there was
a little bit punishment but also I think
it was more than that I think it was
selfish just their own Cleveland way of
going oh well this guy's got to
contribute we got to get him ready and
get him in shape yeah like Todd Haley
went up to lie injury and said I need
you to like make sure this kids like
living at your house yeah and he ended
it with Larry Fitzgerald would take care
his story is a little not being
questioned today you know that right
yeah yeah well he talked about like the
police coming
/ and like the Connie said well the cops
said they smelt it as soon as they
walked in so it doesn't sound like
crumbs were left under the you know he
acted like there was a roach and they
opened up the roach and that they found
weed inside he's like you really gonna
book me for that and then Hugh had this
whole speech about how if I find out
you're lying you're a deep [ __ ]
yeah well we'll see cuz yeah doesn't
sound like you told the whole truth but
speaking of wide receivers this is a
moment that I don't think a lot of
people are talking about online yeah and
I want to share it which is the brief
discussion about maybe bringing in des
it's like some scouting guy with John
Dorsey and you could tell the scouting
guy is really trying to like talk Dorsey
off des it sounds like jorssy once des
so here's the up and back this is my
trade potential trade target stuff
does Brian know he's there at the bottom
it does that's basically 30 units so
like that
all right that's like let me just go
back and keep saying you're reading too
into it what was he saying there I kept
asking the guy let me see your wire
receiver he's like this is just I just
he said just give me the paper but I
could tell that Dorsey is like you
where's des he knows Dorsey knows what
he wants you know didn't it sound like
he wants des there I mean from that's
from that conversation yes and and it
sound like the guys trying to talk him
off of it almost just does I mean I'm
sure des scares people I understand that
I still think des is gonna have value I
think he has a value for a Cleveland
Browns football team if he's willing to
go there the thing that I think
everybody has to get out of their brain
is like des is okay if you play him
outside great but don't expect him to
beat people deep and do all that that
day is over if you want to play him
outside his game's gonna be like a
Michael Crabtree at this point right
he's gonna boss you up it for the 50/50
balls he's gonna catch balls in traffic
but really I look at guys like Dez
Bryant and Brandon Marshall both these
are no longer they should be looked at
as big slot receivers yeah they're not
the greatest route runners in the world
but they're good route runners and
they're gonna be fearless over the
middle they're gonna be able to get
tough yards and things like that that's
where the value is in Dez Bryant and I
think the fact that he never got to play
slot and in Dallas at all it scares the
scouting community because there go
there thing is we've never seen him do
it and I think John Dorsey is probably
like listen he's pretty fast he's pretty
strong he's tough he's fearless he does
not care about content and our number
two battles between Rashad Higgins and
Antonio Callaway exactly right that's
that's where I'm going so that's why
he's saying you're overthinking it
letting Duke Johnson I don't know if I
don't know if Dez Bryant can go from the
slot ten yards and make a 90-degree
angle cut to the round not sure he's
only been one of the greatest athletes
on the planet for the last 50 or some of
these people sound like they have cinder
blocks for brains yeah because they do
because that's like they overthink it
like it's like you know it's like the
Freak at the combine where they're like
well you know that one play and cover
two in college you didn't play
right yeah but he ran four to nine and
when he plays man nobody give her gets
open and when he intercepts a pass he
returns it for a touchdown every time
but you're gonna evaluate that one
mess-up on cover two they look too deep
into it and it's where I always go left
go he sees right so I go to left go
because left go with Ryan our man eagle
is the enemy holiday and bias Ryan
holiday all of that that's Michael Lewis
yeah okay but all of it it's that's
frame of thinking or players and I mean
scouting people fall in love with pliers
and then they get they miss evaluate
because there's like oh you know the guy
at that school told me a great story
about him and he's he's a good kid and I
like the way his film looks okay
anecdotes are such anecdotes are
[ __ ] right you got to cut it out of
your brain it's look it's like when we
go to these training camps and I see all
the reporters on the sidelines they're
like you know is playing well that guy
and the coaches really tell me I was
like one I don't think you know what
you're looking at and to like I don't
really care what the coach told me you
can't always the manipulating anybody
can't always listen to coach look at the
eye in the sky right it doesn't like
Carl Lawson yeah like I still don't know
how he fell but I put him that Bengals
tape the other day holy crap boss man
unbeliev I know I gotta watch them I've
got to watch that game funny I feel like
I watched all the games you did that was
great break up the film here we've got
just fifty percent you do his film
notebook yeah you know what was so Josh
Norman getting back to Washington jets
yeah Sam Darnell he was completely
impressed that sounds like he said dog
this little kid is not making mistakes
you get rookies in here and try to mess
with them and bait them a bit and he's
not having it he impressed me and I
didn't want him to yeah I know he's
impressed me too and I look at that not
only like the game and we talked about
all that on Monday I understand that the
feet that release all that I look at
little things like this where I look at
what he's doing like you know we're in
New York so we get to see little clips
of Sam Donald every night in the news
Sam Donald is working on changing his
motion I see him doing it I see the way
he throws in during warm-ups and things
like that and I think it's only gonna
make him a better thrower he's trying to
limit this drop of the ball and then
this over-the-top motion where the right
hand goes down to his left pocket and if
you really watch him warm-up anybody
that just watched Sam darling you're
gonna see him he's trying to limit the
drop of the ball and he's really coming
across his body like we always talked
about
Rogers or what Brady's done the last few
years where his right arm is finishing
up towards his left pectoral and set him
down there and it just yeah I think we
killed him to do that is that a Jets
coach or I would think so at some point
or buy them maybe it was one of the
Guru's he's worked it with that bird but
I if you I just feel like the smart guys
look around the NFL and they see the
good throwers like I want to throw it
like Aaron Rodgers right and they go let
me what are like oh wait he finishes
over there why am i finishing down there
and then it's little things like that
they you can pick up and I feel like
that's what a lot of the smart
quarterbacks do at least wrote kwan
smith is finally going to be their
Hackenberg first two throws at Eagles
camp were both interceptions and T
unbelievable yes wouldn't you talk about
say immed Arnold and was that the
quarterback that the Giants would have
taken if they didn't take sake well
everything I know yes how good does sake
want have to be and how successful do
the Giants have to be with Eli as a
quarterback need to justify I know I
think the Giants probably do have to go
to the playoffs like the next two years
at least did you just say oh I haven't
like 1,600 total yards but I know what
you're bringing up because it's a very
big conversation up here now I feel like
because the New York papers at the time
its inkwon versus and are white and sand
the way he looked now it's got the giant
fan base and the giant media gun
especially Matt Davis Webb look
did we just mess up the next 10 years of
the organization here and missing on
this quarterback is amazing a sake one
as we know how awesome the quarterback
is and that that position so yeah that's
a real debate up here but no I thinks it
means come on c'est quand the first run
of his career are you kidding me like
get the that was no hole he made two
amazing cuts and then exploded guy by
guys like Denzel Ward who ran the
fastest combine tying on defense and all
that I mean you know he's gonna be a
freak show you uh you uh you want to
talk about Denzel award really quick no
well no I mean Denzel do that not
rookies yeah okay cool let me just do a
few fan updates before we get to jail
and Ramsey first one Sims Olaf go
fantasy league
shout out to Henry meatloaf the NFL the
fantasy drafts are gonna start August
20th and they're gonna conclude
September 4th they've set it all up
props to you guys our draft is on August
28th we are in the golden spleen
conference excited for that I was like a
team together
managing one team bank still have to
come up with our name we could do three
guys two spleens we could do that I
think we should do it like something
more like Odelle Rogers we should
combine our five favorite players or
something we'll call our team Oh Dale
Rogers Turing Beckham you want to know
how you know that this guy's never been
in a fantasy league before he just tried
to name our team Oh Dale Rogers yeah if
you want to come like a fun creative
yeah that was creative
that's Simza stakes all giving you the
keys week one you're setting the lineup
so we didn't have to do anything we just
said hey I'm ready to get all the [ __ ]
the play up submissions right 130 people
have officially applied to be the fuch
to play up I love shout out to Tim Smith
at Team Washington wah every team has at
least one person that has submitted okay
Dallas Philadelphia New England each
have like eight or nine they might need
it Dallas filled up in who else New
England
yeah Dallas and Philadelphia are gonna
definitely need it New England's not
might not have as many but still so how
this is gonna work Tim again thank you
for doing this they're gonna create
committees so that it's not just one
person for each team if there's more
they're gonna all have committees
they're gonna submit reports each week
and then we're gonna keep track of it on
the reddit and on the social and then
when there are certain guys that you're
talking about that you go man this guy's
been great we're gonna check in with the
[ __ ] to play out reports and and kind of
give those guys props on social all
that's what everyone that signed up
awesome hundred and thirty people
volunteering to do it's amazing a lot of
work guys awesome so we appreciate you
guys get ready to watch your film and
and one great shout out here for
Internet Kyle had a great idea that we
are going to implement so internet Kyle
you're the man he said him and his dad
were talking he had a good idea for the
off season Awards next year right we
should have an award called the
Theismann that we award to the best legs
and ass of the rookie coming out so I
think I'm willing to adopt this yep
that next year whichever rookie we
deemed had the best legs and asked we
will give out our new award called the
Theismann as in Joe Theismann no Chris
as in a Heisman Heisman that's got
thighs
I guess you why I don't know when you
get it
but it's still funny that it's Theismann
yeah
and his name is thiis Minh but they
change it this is spell - I'm with dot
in the heisman you're right they change
it speaking of which yes Annie broke his
leg than the most gruesome thing I've
ever seen growing up so it's just my
mind but they're so even Nelson used to
say this all the time that's Mariota so
I think that's one name that we need to
work on okay Mariota but the other one
that was a big future was the
quarterback for the Browns mr. Taylor
Tyrod Tyrod Toronto arrived yes and it's
kind of like Terrell no - Rhett Terrell
Owens - Ron - Ron - Ron - hi Ron yeah I
haven't heard him correct anybody ever
apparently it's a thing I was watching
people eyes Terrell Owens Terrell Owens
- Rod Taylor Mariota man Tyrod sounds a
lot of Tyrod sort I got yeah yeah - rod
but okay cool so classy I say we do this
iftar odds here we call them torrent if
he's not we call him Tyra perfect yeah
he's not gonna know you don't know you
might be amazed it might be a listener
all right so GQ had a big interview with
Jalen Ramsay I'll even know if it was an
interview they just started saying
quarterbacks names and he just started
ripping I wonder if they were planning
to write an actual article and then once
he started talking they were like yeah
we'll just transcribe the quotes and
that's it the article book ended all of
the quarterback [ __ ] talking I just
wasn't interested in it was just like
yeah I get it from my dad okay whatever
so shout-out to clay skipper of GQ for
getting all of this one of my favorite
parts though is once he started getting
on a roll he literally said look I gotta
go down the list of NFL teams I want to
make sure I'm hitting on all the good
quarterbacks he pulled up the pins Jalen
rims he pulled up the polo team that's
copyright infringement Jalen he picked
up his phone just started scrolling
through the team so he did that but it
really started with Josh Allen so here's
how I think we're gonna do this right
pendrick is going to be jail and Ramsey
and he's going to kind of give the takes
and I want to see how many of the takes
we actually agreed welcome yeah so we're
gonna kind of add them up but it mainly
started the guy that's already responded
as Josh Allen aye
jaelyn Ramsey first of all can I know
some of these takes I don't gonna say I
agree with all them but I don't I just
love that he doesn't give a damn about
any of these people he's willing to be
the enemy the time you ever seen
anything like this like a round of these
higher NFL I'm wondering if this is a
new ACL epidemic thing where it's gonna
be repetitive and I have to keep track
on it this happened last year with the
Bennett brothers remember they crapped
on Jay Cutler they talked about Tom
Brady but were they a systematic I'm
gonna go through every quarterback they
definitely had some the person was
saying names to them okay
Jalen just took it and said let me just
get that talking yeah yeah but you know
those are the guys we love we love the
Michael Bennett's we have the jail and
Ranbir's I want I want Jalen Ramsey to
hate every person that's on offense
that's his job it's just more fun to
watch him like that and man it's just
amazing to watch players get flustered
by him when they cover him he gets them
personal like he did with AJ Green and
this AJ Green came up behind him and
chokeslammed him from behind like that's
when you know players are frustrated
like you not even gonna man up against
you like face to face he's just like the
hell with it I'm taking him down and
care if he's looking I don't care if
people think I'm a jerk for taking him
down why he's not looking he's that much
of a jerk you know that you're great
when you have no fear to say these
things right no doubt that's it's only
those guys that really can ever say that
like you know Deon wasn't like attacking
people but he always talked because he
could talk because he was like damn I
cover everybody and nobody ever gets out
but do you think like we're gonna get to
all these all these examples yeah but if
if Jalen Ramsey said something about you
right let's say he said Chris Simms is
trash he's really not that good he's a
system quarterback ball the week of are
you gonna go to your OC and go I want to
draw up some schemes to take a shot and
put Ramsey on an island and and really
set something up like are you good at
like as a player I feel like usually in
those kind of scenarios the offensive
coordinator does it for you he gets
pissed cuz he's like how dare he [ __ ]
called out my quarterback sorry for the
second half word but deal with it okay
so he goes how dare so he usually more
times than not when things like that
happen the team would go out of the way
to help out the
who got trashed by the other player and
they might find two or three plays ago
let's try to screw over Jalen Ramsey
this week and now he's gonna have a
bull's-eye on him for that kind of stuff
because there are teams they're gonna go
Jalen's the kind of guy where I feel
like he's little so you're gonna finally
throw it yeah right but my other
question is like so Josh alamut's we're
gonna get to in a second came out
afterwards and said he's not my teammate
I don't care should these quarterbacks
should they expect their teammates on
social to defend them at all or is it
more work just focus on your own yeah
just go if you play with them and play
against them and that week comes up and
if the players and the team want to
defend them then sure but don't don't
get in the no nonsense conversation
either way right and you know let's just
start there with the Josh Colin thing so
josh is gonna write every all right so
here's what Jalen what time should I
tell we're gonna get to big hill all
right just got to tell him because you
know he's got nothing to do but he wants
to act like he has a side okay here we
go I think Alan is trash I don't care
what nobody say he's trash and it's
gonna show - that's a stupid draft pick
to me we play them this year and I'm
excited as hell I hope he's their
starting quarterback he played a Wyoming
every time he played a big school like
they played Iowa State which is not a
big school in my opinion because I went
to Florida State in Iowa the article he
threw five interceptions and they lost
by a couple touchdowns or something like
that he never beat a big school if you
look at his games against big schools it
was always hella interceptions hell of
turnovers it's like yo if you're this
good why couldn't you do better he fits
that mold he's a big tall quarterback
big arm supposedly I don't see it
personally end quote
so I look at this first what's your take
go ahead just saying I was just gonna
say that this is one that I think Jalen
is kind of speaking and he doesn't know
because he's actually never faced them
yeah all the other ones I feel like he's
watched game film this to me is he read
a bunch of draft scouting stuff he's
been on Twitter it would be like first
of all we know he didn't watch any film
with Josh on it BB like me holding Jalen
and Ramsey responsible for going three
and thirteen as a rookie and going he
was trash why he couldn't win a game the
there were three and thirteen he was the
top-10 pick why wouldn't they better I
mean he's jaylen Ramsey he should have
been able to make the Jaguars better
this quote followed a quote
he said I don't understand why Lamar
Jackson didn't go higher and I felt like
that was the vitriol there right he was
actually upset that Lamar didn't go
higher and the guy he picked was Josh
Allen yeah that's what it felt like to
me yeah I so I'm gonna put this in the
disagree with Jaylin category well I
just don't think it's fair you know like
this so I'm gonna put that in the not
fair I don't think it's fair because one
he doesn't have value but he hasn't
evaluated like what did he do against
big school okay so then but see my
argument to that would be for a guy that
you haven't really played or got seen
what he did in the NFL like again so am
I gonna say Jalen Ramsay played like
crap when Ben Roethlisberger threw for
469 yards and five touchdowns and one
interception the playoff game because he
must have played that crap bet Ben Ben
tore them apart let's get to Bill
Russell so that's so that's where I
don't understand it so you're holding
he's putting the all the blame on the
quarterback that was a one man one man
thing to me that was his worst analysis
yeah because there's nothing to say
about big bad I understand the common
thought about Josh Allen out there I
mean I get it I just think he's gonna
prove a lot of people home Big Ben quote
I think he's decent at best it's not Big
Ben
it's Antonio Brown Big Ben swings the
ball a lot of the time he just slings it
and his receivers go get it he is a
strong arm but he ain't all that I
played him twice last year and he really
disappointed me he'll be in the Hall of
Fame and all that end quote yeah I mean
that to me it's like he's talking about
both sides of his mouth first of all he
threw for 469 yards and five touchdowns
and I mean you know a lot of those ended
up being on AJ booyah where I could
argue also argue man maybe I mean if I
really wanted to be a jerk here which I
don't believe this statement but I could
go AJ bleeeh is the best corner on the
Jacksonville Jaguars why are you been
talking PFF had him the number one rated
corner right wasn't a human umber one
and Jalen's what two or three I don't
know either way I just I don't know why
you would take that shot at Ben
Roethlisberger the guy that basically
kept his team in the game come on let's
get into his head amazing this is
because he threw to pick sixes against
Jacksonville sure and he was awful in
that first game he was now the second
game yeah to say that those
rose where his receivers just going to
get it his minimum and CEO Brown was not
open one time the whole game so that's
where I would push back and go know if
Antonio Brown had no arms and no hands
and he just opened up his pockets those
balls were gonna fall in his pocket yes
so that's just an erroneous statement
altogether to me that's where it sounded
like get a personal cuz he must like
Antonio he got the Josh now and he likes
Tyrod Taylor
so he's mad about that mix up that
they've traded Tyrod Taylor for a Josh
Allen pick that's where I feel like
personal got into this a little bit hey
they got the best of Big Bend the first
time around Big Bend got the best of
them the second time around I mean that
game should have been over a long long
time before that there were 28 to 7
quarterbacks that don't suck next yes so
you have a not fair and one disagrees
yeah the guy asked him who do you think
that doesn't suck right here's what he
said quote Aaron Rodgers does not Tom
Brady doesn't I got to think now about
all the teams I think Marcus Mariota is
a great quarterback for their team I
think Tara Taylor is actually a better
quarterback that he gets credit for
because he doesn't make mistakes he's
honestly a Marcus Mariota type player
where he manages a game really well but
see that's where I would push back
against that whole comment Marcus
Mariota has been a human turnover since
he's been a quarterback in the NFL 13
touchdowns 15 interceptions he's Lee
he's a league leader in fumbles the last
two years so that's he's wrong with that
statement so he finished the quote by
saying he always has they lost to him
twice last this is about Toronto at
least in position to be in the game late
in the game yeah he doesn't have
turnovers that often that's really all
you need especially if you get a good
defense okay so he says that Rodgers
doesn't suck and Brady doesn't suck we
agree with that
okay Mariota and Tirat yeah what do you
think about those two he's right about
his assessment of Tyrod he doesn't get
the credit he deserves to rot sorry he
doesn't get the credit he deserves so
you get that I do I agree with it yeah
Mario Mario topping Mariota he's being
conscious of a guy that's in his
division that like Josh said has beaten
them twice last year and he's not trying
to ruffle the feathers of that of that I
think that got in the way that says now
I'm gonna put this in a rare Jalen
Ramsay is being like a little article
with that one little
yes okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna say one
political so we got to disagree we got a
not fair not fair was to josh allen
right and then a political to Mariota
interest yeah all right now wait just
before you go there hold on a second
because I just I want to just make sure
and make sure we clarify Oda in three
season has thirty four interceptions
thank you yeah I mean he's the 27th
Randy was eleven volunteer in his career
so I don't know where that ranks it's
it's bad I'm just telling you I don't
know either but I can just tell you
people so that's that's my problem with
that comment there but either way go
ahead Jimmy Garoppolo yeah I don't know
yet just cuz when they beat us his hi
picked up they were like he beat the
number one defense it was all schemes he
didn't beat us it wasn't like he diced
us up it was literally all schemes they
were doing flat routes to the wide open
fullback and he's running for 20 yards
down the field four times during the
game so he didn't really dice us up it
was their fullback and their tight end
on over routes yeah but if you know how
to work within your scheme that it means
you're good I guess you could say he's
good
Kyle Kyle end quote
Kyle alright so then go into that like
okay yes so I mean I agree yeah I mean
Jimmy Garoppolo is overrated at this
point I still still think he's gonna be
very great yes I think really at the end
of the year I think that quote was a
hundred percent a key but I think it's a
hundred percent accurate as well you
know was your analysis after the game no
doubt about it I mean Kyle exposed the
scheme of that defense and you know I
think to add to that point to what he
says about Rogers and Brady yeah I mean
we know about Rogers offense it's like a
preschool offense and he got to play him
I think as was rookie year or either way
just even the season last year right so
he's seen Rogers go I mean with these
basic plays just make throws that were
like ridiculous and Brady the same thing
Brady made some unbelievable throws in
that AFC Championship game to where it's
not the scheme it was actually the
physical ability of the player and I'm
sure he respects that he feels very
similar about Jared Goff let's go to
Jared Goff here we go Jared Goff quote
he's average to above-average
let me just say this Sims your take on
Jared Goff is that you kind of believe
he's a little of a system guy you
believe that he is good but he's not in
the upper tier of quarterbacks
athletically no he's one of the I think
he's one of the worst first picks of the
draft in the history of the sport like I
don't mean to like say that but he's
dead he does
nothing that bout him physically that
jumps off the board let's see if Jalen
agrees he's average to above-average he
reminds me of Jimmy Garoppolo a little
bit year one he wasn't good
he wasn't even good enough to earn his
own starting role like if you the number
one pick you expect to start now period
he wasn't ready to do that he wasn't
able to do that then when he did get in
he didn't really do that good but in his
second year they got a new offensive
coordinator your offensive coordinator
is just your Brainiac when we played
them it felt like his offensive
coordinator was drawing up perfect plays
and he was hitting the open man for what
his team asked him to do yeah he's good
end quote
is Jalen Ramsey listening to the podcast
I mean I feel like he is he might be
that's a hundred percent agree some of
these that some of these are plain as
day like we're gonna get into it plain
as day for everybody else so people go
oh Jalen's this [ __ ] and we're gonna
know we've been saying this the entire
time right I don't want to be I don't
want to get excuses I agree with Jalen a
hundred percent on Jared Goff and
apparently people are gonna say that
this is crazy
I think he's spot-on and I'm happy
somebody's saying Yeah right it is it's
nice to hear players say this is I mean
this there's a lot of people that think
things and you think it's normal and I
need you to understand that the rest of
the world thinks you're [ __ ] crazy
yeah well I know I guess I can't listen
to those people cuz they're crazy and
they don't know what they're talking
about so I just listen to me so this is
I mean that analysis a Jared guy well
it's a hundred percent what you always
send me no doubt about it yeah and then
let's just think about the game when
they played a minimun I mean first of
all when they played them Jared Goff was
11 for 21 for 124 yards and a touchdown
that was the enemy remember protection
they blocked a punt member and gave him
the short field let me just see if
there's anything else
sir line had a 56 yard field goal right
and yeah the touchdown came off the
block punt and then zero line had
another one and and then he had a four
yard touchdown pass did you know that
when Todd Gurley played pretty well had
a few big yes exactly what you agree
with Jared Goff completely I mean yes
and Jared Goff might prove us wrong and
he's a starting quarterback in the NFL
but yes I'm just hit what he is saying
and what I have always said is you could
put definitely the top 25 quarterbacks
in football in the Rams offense and they
would have thrown for 28 touchdowns and
seven interceptions last year and I
would say that if you put the top ten
quarterbacks maybe the top 14
quarterbacks in the Rams offense from
last year it would have been more like
40 and 7
they're 40 and eight it would have been
a totally different game people just
look at the bottom line and go oh that's
good and then it goes back to her old
thing what was there to be had and there
were so much there to be had yes in a
lot of those games with Jared golf and
it didn't happen so I want to say this
because I know we're gonna get to
bortles later and like Matt Ryan and I
know that a lot of people say that we're
hating on certain people yeah I want to
explain the reason why we get this way
the reason is when Jared Goff comes in
at the seventh most likely to win the
MVP and everyone out there is writing
these glowing articles we kind of feel
like it's our job to go stop miss
educating people because you tell people
that Jared Goff is better than Matt
Stafford you're hurting people's brains
why don't we go to stab they're just
lying all right flat-out wrong but he
said he said Stafford to Matt's dad he
did everybody all right so Matt Stafford
quote I think he's straight I don't
think he's the best quarterback out
there but he does what he's got to do
yeah maybe he doesn't had to play him
yet really has he I don't think so
hey see straight but obviously he's seen
enough to go okay good right I mean
Matthew Stafford is one of those guys
that I don't think people are really
know about him until they go oh we have
to play him and now the coach showed us
the third down reel and you go holy [ __ ]
I didn't realize he makes this many
amazing throws all the time he's one of
those guys and then when you see him in
person
TV doesn't do it justice with how hard
the ball is spinning and coming at you
with miles per hour that's where I think
people gonna go whoa Stafford's let me
agree with Ramsey on that one I think
he's straight he does what he got yeah I
think so they didn't really say you
might want to Shawn next yes so a little
positive here that's just a shot and
Carson one right here we go I heard this
one quote he'll be the league MVP in a
couple years 100% there's not even a
debate about that him and Carson Wentz
for every year starting now until 5 to
10 years it's gonna be them - they're
that good yeah I mean agree with both of
them got a hundred percent I mean we
know that I mean the Shawn Watson has a
chance in three years to be the best
quarterback in football I think either
one of those guys know you know whence I
know they're both coming back from
injuries but everyone both of those guys
when totally healthy have chance to be
first-ballot Hall of Fame type
quarterbacks Watson and Wentz
that talented there that natural at the
position they have that kind of
leadership they have it mmm so even
though they've had such a small sample
size you can kind of extrapolate that
and go hopeful whence now I mean I've
seen enough of once I was impressed with
him his rookie year and he took a giant
step up his second year and people are
forgetting that he carried the team the
first half of the year until the team
finally caught up and then they became
this well-oiled machine and deshaun
Watson his potential
I mean deshaun Watson I mean you could
argue that four-game run he had was as
good as anybody in football ask gee I
don't know if anybody played better
through those three or four weeks and he
did and went up to New England to New
England the next year next week in
Seattle that was jaw-dropping I mean it
was a City yeah Kansas City was good not
great but yes I mean and then of course
the big run against the bangles that
basically won them the game he can make
game-changing game-winning type plays at
that position just like when Sir Rogers
or Brady's ripped through the page to
here laughing or Stafford Stafford can
do that too he just doesn't have enough
help to always get them there to do that
quick update Weaver Wilson we've agreed
with Ramsey eight times yeah one has
been not fair one we've disagreed with
and one was political
all right dak Prescott dak he's good
he's alright he's okay
I'll put it that way zeke elliot runs
that team though everything runs around
Zeke man spot-on
I mean dak is good don't get it doc is
definitely in the top 15 quarterbacks in
football he's not in the top ten and I
do think he's gonna get better because
he's big he runs well and he's a very
accurate pure thrower the football now
again I don't know if their stats are
ever gonna lead him to being like a
league leader in anything cuz like he
said the point is Ezekiel Elliott was
Rookie of the Year I don't give a [ __ ]
who voted for it because that was
ridiculous I mean I still can't even
believe that I mean it was really one
rookie of the year and people wanted him
those same people who voted in for him
too that wanted him to be benched for
Tony Romo the last three weeks of the
year because they didn't think he was
playing well enough but then he was
Rookie of the Year sorry good Kirk
Cousins yeah I think he's good I think
he's a winner he's a hell of a
competitor coming off the play-action
he's the best quarterback in the league
play-action passing he's a hell of a
quarterback alright I think that's very
fair too you know Kirk is not gonna wow
you with his ability but he's gonna wow
you with his
aggressive nature his ability to see a
defense really quick and then just pull
the trigger that's what he does so well
I have been I've been amazed at the
disrespect given to Kirk Cousins yeah
because Washington it's cuz the
Washington needed us they didn't want to
invest because they negotiated poorly
and didn't want to invest like two
hundred million dollars he got CMAs not
good yeah he wasn't good for that number
he's not Aaron Rodgers he's not Tom
Brady but the disrespect he's gotten it
was very refreshing for me to hear
someone like Jalen Ramsay come out be
like oh no that guy's a ball yeah it's
ridiculous and it's all started by
Washington DC in that area that's what
it's really started by because there's a
faction of people that are just mad that
he was the one that overtook the rg3
magic as I burp it's disgusting you want
to tell your dad we need a few extra
minutes here it's about to get juicy all
right should we want to bring him on for
some of these no cuz he's gonna talk to
my next one Derek Carr Derek Carr I
think he's good okay agreed
I think so too last year was a not a
good year right not a good year but he
wasn't healthy the team was
dysfunctional they had a lot of issues
with the team all together but I think
Derek Carr yes what we saw the first few
years is the guy we're gonna see once
again we've had a met I think like 14 15
or 16 on your quarterback so that's kind
of the range of good yes I would say
right Eli Manning it's not really Eli I
think it's Odell Beckham I won't say
Eli's good I'll say Odell's good and
their connection is good
100% I I there's very few players in
football that play defense and I mean
this and I again I'm not even when Eli
was winning Super Bowls I can promise
you there was big-time players that I
used to talk to another defenses
nobody's ever seen it with Eli nobody's
ever thought no player I've ever known
has ever looked at Eli and held him in
the regard the way the New York media
does they're the the New York media in
the New York fan base who's very loyal
it's the Giants Eli won them two Super
Bowls and he one of them in stunning
fashion against the evil empire of the
Patriots and all that so that the giant
fans love him but I can tell you around
the NFL nobody has ever looked at Eli
and gun man I mean he is a leap woo he
does all these things awesome
that's that he's great I mean he's been
great as far as in clutch situations
he's a good thrower the football he's
been a pretty good decision maker
through his career but at this point of
his career yes I mean yeah I had him at
38th ranked the best quarterback in
football and I don't think I'm far off I
got into an argument about dagger right
I was wearing my Aaron Rodgers shirt and
they were the guy goes I don't know who
the hell number 12 is but he ain't to go
Tom Brady's that go and I was like why
he goes because he's got five and I said
so you think Eli Manning is a better
quarterback that and Dan Marino that was
like video he goes and he goes he goes
he does got two Super Bowls and I was
like sir what does that matter stop
talking stop talking I just got a look
at the team's like Aaron Rodgers gonna
go to the Hall of Fame and we're gonna
look at his team and go you never played
with another hall-of-famer other than
Charles Woodson right and we're gonna
look at we're gonna maybe Julius Peppers
but that was at year 12 of his career
Clay Matthews a possible probably not I
mean he's gonna be an NFL legend but you
know people forget that like Moss's
first ballot Hall of Fame Rob Gronkowski
he's gonna be first ballot Hall of Fame
Wes Welker is the greatest slot receiver
we've seen since slot receivers were
invented okay he's had tremendous
offensive line play around him
Horace depose Cory's Dylan not good
Richard Seymour's a Hall of Fame player
Vince Wilfork so Hall of Fame player Ty
Law is a Hall of Fame player and you
haven't mentioned the coach or the court
that's what I mean sir and the coach
will be a Hall of Fame right I mean they
might name the craft is gonna get in the
hole name the league after Belichick in
30 years they managers called Bill
Belichick like Vince Lombardi and
availability trophy so that's where I
get annoyed with that whole conversation
because like I'm so sick of hearing all
Brady does it by himself
yeah Brady's had some teams that have
not had the star power and they've done
really well I don't think Roberts
mentioned enough and the greatest NBA
player of all time he's got seven rings
right that's the I don't know Russell
Wilson Russell's good I think he's a
really good leader to the short one here
yeah I agree yeah all right I mean
Russell tore their butt up to a little
bit didn't he drew brees had some
success yeah I'm a fan of Drew Brees I
think Drew Brees is really good even at
this age he still runs everything yeah
I mean he he does certainly you know
again yet drew brees is still really
good at this age certainly he's another
guy though that I would have loved to
him say like the offense is awesome and
all those things have to go into that
conversation as to him and Sean Payton's
gonna go down in history as one of the
greatest offensive minds in the history
of the sport
so is that an agree or disagree no
that's it agree okay agree yeah Andrew
Luck I don't really think he's that good
him and T why Hilden had a connection in
the past that made him stand out a
little bit more but I don't think he's
good I mean he hasn't played injure luck
yet has he
so that's right I would just I would
push back against that right is this a
not fair
a disagree I mean I totally disagree
with that one I mean Andrew Luck when he
is when he is playing and healthy he's
looking it up since he's in the
conversation from one of the five best
in the sport you know I mean I don't
know he doesn't play they go four and
twelve okay 2016 what he played he
played that year pretty banged up right
I'm just trying to look through that
either either way I mean his stats in
that year were all good I mean he beat
Jacksonville that last year in the last
game of the year but man I just see I
don't believe that statement I mean
Andrew Luck is a game changer again
Andrew Luck went to the playoffs his
first three years there with no but
he'll tell me who was on those teams who
was on the defense right I mean it's
just it's nothing so yeah I don't agree
with that one Phillip Rivers quote I
think he's pretty good end quote
yeah I mean he is and I think the one
thing that goes unnoticed
you know about Phillip Rivers first of
all he is really good the offense is
pretty good but I would argue that
Phillip Rivers wide receiving corps and
people around him are as good as anybody
in football I mean think about it it's
it's it's a key now on Keenan Allen its
Tyrell Williams its Travis Travis
Benjamin it's Mike Williams is coming
it's ty Williams who's really good it's
been good tight end play Tonio gate I
mean I would I would say that's some
word like I said the other day I think
it's one of the best units in football
hawai receiving chordal well there's
like four or five Chargers right there
like the whole unit is phenomenal all
right ready for this yeah
Atlanta Chris signs oh no so he asked
the first question yeah I know okay yeah
so the question was what's the Atlanta
quarterback never know
Jalen Ramsey we didn't know was the
order and said what's the Atlantis
quarterbacks name
and then the reporter said Matt Ryan and
he said oh okay so here's the Matt Ryan
quote I think Matt Ryan's overrated you
can't tell me you win MVP two years ago
and then last year you a complete bust
and you still got Julio Jones there's no
way that should ever happen I don't care
you know what that tells me that tells
me that Shanahan left went to San
Francisco got Garoppolo made Garoppolo
this big thing and now Garoppolo is a
big name and now Matt Ryan has this bad
year all right well was it really you or
was it your coach he was doing what was
asked of him and it was making him look
really really good I mean I don't think
we could agree with anything more yeah I
mean I think Matt Ryan's a good player
okay Matt Ryan had a good year last year
it was actually the best he's played it
was the best he's played with having to
do things with just his physical ability
that's where I would say with that but
yes I mean again Verne I know we sound
like haters on him but he is it's just
the way it is he's a little overrated in
the public eye because of the numbers
and everything like that and I think a
lot of people look at it and just go
yeah I mean Julio Jones is the guy in
that offense there's no doubt and I'm so
sick of hearing about Julio Jones and no
touchdowns the reason he has no
touchdowns is because they're red zone
offense thinks and Matt Ryan can't make
special throws that you need to make
inside the red zone like a Brady or
Rogers or deshaun Watson who can
scramble and then throw a 105
mile-per-hour fastball 30 yards through
the middle of the defense into a tiny
little keyhole he can't do that so
that's why Julio Jones touchdowns fall
off you know if Julio doesn't catch the
slant and break six tackles and run for
another 60 yards
he's not gonna score a touchdown cuz
Matt Ryan's not great at some of those
red zone type throws I think when you
look at a lot of Jalen's analysis too
he's he he when he's talking about some
of these players he talks about that
like he talks about Zeke when you asked
about dak he talks about Odell when you
asked about Eli he talks about Antonio
Brown when you talk about Big Boi and
this kind of aligns with what we've
always said which is the quarterbacks
not always the most important person I
think that's why he's going off on this
because he's probably so sick of hearing
about quarterbacks which I understand
about was defense I beg and screw these
quarterbacks and all that bait they're
the reason we win that's all it's the
only reason go ahead
one left yeah one left portals blake
bortles quote blake do what he got to do
I think in crunch time moments like last
year's playoff game not as a team
because we would have trusted him but I
think as an organization we should have
trusted him more to keep throwing in we
kind of got complacent and conservative
and I think that's why we lost we
started running it on first and second
down throwing it on third down every
single time we were out there the
Patriots caught on to that the reporter
followed up and said how much trouble do
you guys give him in practice and Jalen
responded we never go against him unless
it's training camp we never go against
them and practice during the season
reporter fouls up and says they go
against the twos and Jalen responded yet
the scout team plus we don't want to
hurt his confidence that'll probably
hurt his confidence I mean it goes in
line is that common yeah that was the
first thing I said was it's not to face
one yeah it is it is pretty common like
you go a little bit through the season
but it's not a whole lot no like a lot
of times the only times you're gonna go
against ones because you're not
preparing against your defense anymore
right so what happens a lot of times is
you're going against Cal you're going in
a scout team or even the scout team
though can be the starters a lot of
times real like New England would have
some of their starters run some of the
scout team things for a few plays and go
like hey just get out here it gets them
some reps it's drawn on a car and
everybody's got some of these coverages
we're putting on so it's not like you're
getting a dead rat just do whatever they
might do four or five reps and then you
get the scout teamers and second guys in
there they can get some reps too but
that is common but I mean it just goes
in line with what we've always I mean
nobody ever really talks much about his
ability play off Blake is good people
can say whatever they want but play off
Blake is good I think that's how it is
with a lot of teams as long as you do
what the team is asking to do as well
the rest of the team then you could be
considered good I felt like this was I
felt like he was trying to tell us that
he wasn't good but I could tell that
he's still defending him this one I
either don't agree with her it's
political which is quarterback of it is
political it's a quarterback of his own
damn team he is telling you if he was
really thought he was a ball we'd be AG
man Blake bortles is
really good I don't know what
everybody's thinking he makes these
throws in these plays every week in
practice said that he he skated around
the issue oh we gotta trust them more I
mean for him willing to say that it
would shake his confidence to face us in
practice the big thing is where I think
he's missing in the conversation about
the New England thing is more than they
didn't have trust in him because some of
the games they lost during the year he
lost their trust but some bad plays down
the stretch they got to the AFC
Championship by not letting Blake
bortles do things like that that's what
they did right they stayed with the
script of what got them there and that's
what carried over to AFC championship
game and they were like damn we're not
gonna give him the ball with 55 seconds
left 11 throw an interception or
something like this when we've dominated
the whole first half then we go in with
a bad taste in our mouth I know it's
unfair that I wanted him to be honest
about bortles but for me it's tough
because it's like you had 1 2 3 4 5 21
quarterbacks she went through right and
you were honest about all of them yeah
and then it just felt like so dishonest
but I know it's a team but you're Mr
honesty but it's almost law my dad just
to get him going calm but keep going it
to me it's called a house Matt to me
it's just a little crazy cuz it's like
you're willing to put your name on it
which one I applaud because most guys
wouldn't do this we agreed with him on
16 of the 21 yeah we thought one wasn't
fair
Josh Allen we thought two we disagreed
Big Ben and Andrew Luck and two were
political Mariota and bortles his
analysis of quarterbacks is actually
spot-on I mean he's a smart kid yes I
just
Icom wanted him to take it to board I
know but he's not gonna do that he wants
to win a Super Bowl and he doesn't want
to have to fight the offensive line in
the locker room the minute he gives up
one what's up big Phil faith have you
Phil have you ever had someone say like
a teammate speak bad of you in the
public like have you ever watched that
happen on a team or teammates in general
well I've had a lot of players talk bad
about me publicly so I don't know
teammates like people that were on the
Giants when you were no I don't think ok
no
I'm just trying to think but especially
in the Parcells error
oh yeah nobody around okay so that you
know that was just not even thought of
in fact he made everybody be afraid to
talk to the press and he had two rookies
one time after a preseason game given
all these interviews and everything and
I'm not gonna tell you the names right
now but he says the next day in the
meeting he says so and so it's also
stand-up who in the hell made you to the
team smokes is for this team we won
before your ass got here and we'll win
without you I hear another epping word
from either one of you the rest of time
I'll get rid of you forever so there you
go so that so I took care of all the how
we talk to the press stuff so Phil what
we're talking about is Jalen Ramsey was
doing an interview with GQ and he pretty
much talked his opinions about 21
quarterbacks in the NFL yeah you know
Tom Coughlin really well he just
suspended Ramsey a week for like
tweeting things I was how is Tom gonna
react to arguably the best player on his
team and maybe the best cornerback in
the league saying this is he gonna be
like oh I want him to be confident or is
he gonna kind of like discipline him
again well I think the suspension is
going to take care of him we always say
Tom Coughlin Tom Coughlin let's don't
forget there's another guy that's just a
younger Tom Coughlin down there his
name's Doug Marrone right I mean this
team went nine straight days and full
pads a training camp what one of the
team in the NFL did that or has done
that right any other team did it we
would have an all-out alert and you know
guys crying and and the media right no
they can't do this and whatever so to me
it's just the balance like I think about
Parcells and lt where you guys have
always said you need to let him do his
thing cuz that's him and I feel like the
Jaguars kind of have to let jail and
Ramsey talk where else he'd feel like
he's being kind of caged in well I
listen I think they understand it's
different now we always and I talk about
you know the old days
different I I get it but sometimes it
can go overboard I they took it as going
overboard and listen come on I don't
know what to say it's it's um it I'm
kind of fine with it but it's a little
mean-spirited too in other words yes and
and you know come on don't do that to
yourself now everybody maybe that's what
he wanted you know I was driving home
listed on the radio and somebody says
well you know this'll probably get him a
few commercials and this are really
giving a platform and giving my identity
and all this stuff and I just stood
there you know you're right it brings
more attention to him it makes him more
viable or sellable to advertisers and
you know that that's that's the world
now it could be I will say this I don't
think he's that guy I think he loves
football so much and he's that
passionate about it and he just wants to
crap on everybody and he ain't afraid to
be the enemy of the people
well you know I'm not gonna disagree
with you there yeah because he is
unbelievable
and I mean this and only in a good
phrase he is a dog out there he I mean I
mean he just everybody he has no respect
for any receiver he sees and you know
that there's just a handful of guys in
the league when you're a quarterback you
always got to know where they're at
and when you throw to their side you're
extra careful and you really shout out
to throw at them yeah right okay so
what's the difference I got to throw at
AJ blue yay so yeah it is a difference
and Jalen Ramsey is right up there with
you know four or five guys I can name in
the league you know Deion Sanders of
course was one you know in my day it was
down green Darrell Green yes absolutely
I mean my god we had a direct order
if you throw one pass at his side the
whole game I will take you out right
away
well I didn't no way dissing clarify
this because I think so and I think I've
heard you say this before but didn't you
say you used to not even be able to
double move
Darryl Greene you'd had to do triple
moves cuz he'd be a he'd already he was
so fast that he would catch up on the
double move so that's what started you
guys on the out and up and then the
comeback oh yeah yeah no question no
question if you double moved him and
folding you keep would outrun the
football right that's right I'll never
forget we threw a pass
well this is not a good example I threw
one over the middle to Maurice carthon
yeah and I swear to you right down the
middle of the field at RFK he had about
a 30 yard I was there I remember I was
there yeah that's right the whole time
he's running two years at the ball
predicted because he goes I know Darryl
Greene's closing fast
right it was like it was amazing he ran
him down in like twenty yards so but
there were guys like that Michael Haynes
you know it is in his heyday yeah just
guys it hey Aqib Talib when he was at
the top of his game Darrelle Revis yeah
oh my gosh I mean not only they
physically good and you talk about this
thing but they're mentally really good
right they know how to bait you you know
oh go ahead and drill that out you can
have a 1 or 2 as a key to leave told me
he says hey hey feel I'll give him one
or two but that third one's going to the
house Hall said the same thing yes he
was going to let you guys DeAngelo Hall
right he was gonna use gonna let Chris
throw the out and be like get real
comfortable with that yeah he was
talking about because you know I think
like a what quarter of my career
interceptions with the DeAngelo Hall so
you're talking to him last week but he
goes yeah you know you got to think
about think what a corners thinking okay
I'll give you a couple out cuts but now
I got a read on it and I feel it or
whatever and then they're they're gonna
go for one and so what you hit four or
five of those out cuts but the one you
throw an interception on if it's to a
corner it's usually full speed the other
way so big fill in the last podcast one
of our fans asked when you're at a home
game do you stay at a hotel or your home
the night before and Chris was saying
that when he was playing you'd still say
at a hotel
but that when you were playing you at
Chris you thought it was crazy that Dan
Reeves Dan Reeves changed the rule for
you right dad were you got to stay home
those years and Chris was say home Chris
was saying it was so weird because like
here you are focused for the game and
Chris is like hey Dad want to watch
college football tonight like do you
remember Chris those Saturday nights
before the games absolutely they were
great yeah no they were great yeah -
what what do you think I was gonna do at
the hotel anyway yeah you know the the
playbook was done I wasn't going to sit
in there and study anymore my god
there's nothing to learn on Saturday
night if I have to learn somebody
Saturday night
then we're gonna I'm not gonna do well
anyway but I remember staying home I
just loved it and just sitting there
watch the having dinner with the family
and not having that you know looking at
the clock the whole time during the
incident okay I gotta leave at 6:15
right it's four o'clock for two hours
yeah you know I mean it was awful
all right so we're on the subject I was
gonna go somewhere else but all right so
then you got to stay home and this is
the best part of the year he wakes up on
a November day right and you gotta play
the Arizona Cardinals back in that day
yes
so go ahead just tell the story of that
day and how you woke up and how
everything went from there well that day
you were playing in whatever they call
the peewee championship right I was the
MVP I played good what are you gonna do
yeah you played really well and of
course the game that you played in a lot
of those guys went on to play major
college football - what yeah made it yes
at that age
but I said Diana you coming to my game
no I'm going to see if Christopher I
said okay I'd say of course I already
knew where I stood but that was the
morning I woke up set on the edge of the
bed went oh my god I had equilibrium
problems to say the least and I could
not sit up I could not get up and walk
across the room and I said Diana I don't
think I can play today and you know go
ahead tell it all because [ __ ]
you're gonna play dirty
you're gonna be I said I can't move that
the room is spinning I'm ready to throw
up I can remember hearing you walk down
the hallway and he like hit the side of
the wall cuz he lost his balance I was
like no I really couldn't
right walk straight so I walk it takes
me a minute to walk five feet into the
bathroom and I stood Darren oh my god
she goes okay I'm gonna call the trainer
Ronnie Barnes I called him and she my
wife called him and said okay she said
to get you down there as soon as
possible
so they got me down there I can't
remember they gave me an IV and they
gave me some medicine I laid there I
felt a little better is you remember
that day the good thing was it was kind
of a nice October or November day and
we're probably right and there was a
little mist in the air or whatever yeah
not a cool is perfect and I played and
played well I made some throws to win
the game at the very end right but if I
got touched at all the field and stadium
would start spinning on me like in
circles and I was like oh man we'll
throw up and I had to grab my knees I
can watch the tape I bet it's on there
every time I got touched I had to stand
up put my hands on my knees and breathe
and finally my eyes would come back into
focus and I'd go ahead and play and you
know looking back maybe I needed that
more cuz I really threw the ball really
well that day it's funny dance like that
because now you don't think about little
things I feel like sometimes when I lost
my spleen in that game I was I was like
worried about just surviving I wasn't
always like stressing about oh did I get
this blitz right or whatever else it can
do that - you still had a vertigo
yeah it is true though and Adam think
about you know we always hear Michael
Jordan is sick oh my god I'm gonna go
bet heavy because you know I said I knew
he was gonna play well you know the he
which he did in playoff some games oh we
don't think he's going to play but he
does and he just goes because there is
something to that and it's because the a
like you said Christopher you're so
focused on one thing right you're not
thinking about anything else and it
really just
the zero in or whatever you want to call
it zero and what you got to do that it
that is real and it works and then to
finish the story okay before we so so
this is back in the day there's no cell
phone so like if Bill Parcells called
the house like I might answer the phone
and be like but the newspaper people
used to call the house too so Steve sir
be dad was he working for the Daily News
at that time well probably with the New
York Post New York Post he calls the
next morning sorry and this would be the
end of the story he calls my mom picks
up the phone and sir B knows that my dad
wasn't feeling well
but my mom you know my mom goes oh yeah
I'm just so glad he played and she goes
yeah what did you say anything in the
morning and she goes I just told him to
suck it up and then the next day on the
cover the New York Post it says Simms
wife says suck it up I remember you told
us that story in the office I want to go
get to the the post archives and see if
we didn't find another member of 1993
the brother you know you think when you
saw that paper hey you know mom well
yeah I'm not gonna tell you what the
things were but I knew some like really
secrets about the NFL and certain things
they're gonna happen a coach is gonna be
fired or whatever right and I told my
wife yeah some friends of mine in the
media business called the house and she
goes oh did you hear the news sources
get hired and this guy's taking a job
excuse me what did a few times yeah
Diana you're a great source I'll call
you next week guys oh my god Diana you
can't you know I got on the phone once
and said look just you can't write it
don't say it you know you can't no no
don't worry it's gonna be okay I'm you
know sweating bullets I like or whatever
somebody's gonna find out I said
something but you know what it never did
no so Diana was the first Adam Schefter
seriously you you're right right or
whatever I don't know what car Adam
Schefter
or she was ddd shifter and that's so me
calling yes she did it was pretty funny
stuff
what are y'all been talking about today
what we did we really just talked a lot
about the the whole you know Jalen
Ramsey thing a few way down the radio
and I'm listening I'm going okay on a
scale of one to ten I've got a big zero
on how much I care about this
interesting me we agreed of the twenty
one quarterback said he talked to I
agreed with him on sixteen of them we
thought that he was unfair about Josh
Allen he just didn't know what he was
talking about
we thought that we disagreed with him on
Big Ben and Andrew Luck he said that
they weren't really that good and we
disagreed and we thought that he was
being very political in his answers
about Mariota and bortles but we agreed
with him about like you know seventy
percent of the answers yeah I know
that's great
and you know but III wasn't gonna go
into analyze him what he said I just
don't care yeah here you know he's just
talking and and in listen it's kind of
who he is and you know what every locker
room you know I've said all these things
but I don't know you know a locker room
needs that group of guys which we've
talked about before many times yeah and
I guarantee you he just doesn't say D I
mean I'm sure he walks in that locker
room every day yeah and he is shooting
things out of that mouth and he just
kind of everybody on the team probably
loves it and cuz he's he's got
personality and it's you you need that
stuff so I look that's why I mean what
he said I didn't get into analyze it all
he just Big Ben and they said you know I
don't care yeah just don't care it means
nothing to me and I don't want to talk
we'r I was on a show I was like oh my
god we're really gonna talk about this
okay look you're so altruistic Phil how
long are you going to avoid playing me
in ping-pong this summer
what's that how long are you going to
avoid playing me in ping-pong this
summer you know listen avoid to that is
really ridiculous to say that and then I
don't know what figure now but we do
want to get you here in the office for
one of these next podcast so Benny I'm
talking about it so no the summers
flying by and every day it's man I just
I'm trying I'm actually trying to do
some work on the Dallas Cowboys right
now so alright I just got home not long
ago and I'm looking at the roster you
know what it's better than you thought
right
it's it's a lot better than I thought I
know I think a lot of a lot of big
[ __ ] on that team oh man oh man and
you know Rod Marinelli and I'm Chris
Chris Rashard yes I said it right he's
the DB coach there now right and I am
yeah that's a nice addition he walks
around carries a big stick now yeah
right you know I mean this guy is he's a
little bit like Coach Wilkes was it in
in Detroit yeah no I get it you're right
I mean he's one of those underrated
defensive coordinators that first of all
we talked about the Cowboys I think we
both have the last few years gone they
could have used some help in their
coverage and some of the things they do
there and I think that he could help
that out cuz marinelle he's a front
seven guy anyways and you know he's
gonna get that group revved up yeah yeah
even against II shoot I forgot the guy
that does the color for the 49ers I'm
watching the game Tim Ryan yes right and
he he just goes oh my god he goes the
Cowboys it's just they just everybody be
bring out there just can kill the
quarterback that's right and you know I
just went wow that was interesting
because he really follows the football
very closely and you know he was saying
some things just that that you know the
49ers weren't quite ready for what was
coming on about by the Dallas Cowboys
yeah it looked like that all right dad
thanks a lot you guys have a good day
Adam see you later man
all right he went to go to later field
just ran out of the room to take a pee
so yeah he'll be back in 40 minutes he's
so slow all right I'll see you dad have
a good day hey Phil was talking that
entire time left go he literally just
doesn't fun
you didn't so you're telling me I had a
chance to go to the bathroom wash my
hands come back and he hung up on the
Cowboys and he went down a little
wormhole there so it was good and you
know what he actually had a good topic
that I think will maybe bring up with
him next week that he he said it to be
on the phone yesterday perfect timing
buddy yeah bring it up but I'll save it
for next week just because I thought it
was a good dog preview it do I need to
write this down or something it was a
little something on Lamar Jackson okay
and John back his bet just no no just a
conversation we had about him and the
league and how they deal with people
like him this day and age I thought I
was kind of an interesting little tidbit
Phil Simms and Lamar Jackson the NFL
coming up thank you only on the Sims and
left copepod all right sim Jory to give
some interesting scouting report let's
do it alright so we are gonna focus on
pre-season week one by the way
super excited for pre-season week two
just to kind of sit down and watch all
the games in terms of week - how do
teams usually approach week - yeah week
- you're gonna get certainly more snaps
by the starters and the people that are
expected to be performing during the
regular season you're gonna get semi
game planning this week right
you're gonna definitely have like you
know whoever it is that's playing we're
gonna look at some film of them this
week where the week before they might
have not looked at anything and they
just had an agreement with the coach
like hey you're not gonna bring a crazy
bug you're gonna bring just basic
blitzes like we're gonna play man-to-man
right conversations go on before this
week is going to be no we're gonna watch
some film from them from the preseason
game one we're gonna probably go back
and watch just a little of last year and
prepare ourselves for summer they're
crazy because I have to imagine the
coaches are also practicing their play
calling timing and their own you know
their own strategy like yeah you have to
get in the flow of gold you like
studying a team yeah they're coming and
they're gonna do a flow of you know
organizing their week to week game plan
approach - with the new guys they got
and things they've evaluated throughout
the first three to four weeks a training
camp to go you know man I came into the
season thinking we would be good at this
but I've been proven wrong over the last
two weeks of training camp and I've got
to adjust how I want to attack whatever
it may be - is more than one three is
more than tureens yeah three is treated
like a real game for the most part and
four is four is basically you might as
well just let their the the pliers the
starters are getting to rest and now
train again like really trained to get
big and strong
get their legs back on them so they can
be explosive as hell for a week one I am
a degenerate gambler but even I would
not bet on week four of the preseason
but we just coming up week one you went
back and looked at some of your favorite
players to go from offense to defense
what did you think of DJ Moore and the
Carolina Panthers the first round wide
receiver you were very excited about him
pre dream right where did you think when
what you just saw in that first week I
mean he didn't start right they started
torii some
and Funchess but when they brought in
the first third receiver he was the
first guy to go out there first of all
his body jumps out to me he's got that
special legs that I like to see in a
running back like a running back /
receiver that they're special to me like
we've seen the Percy Harvin's of the
world have and some of those kind of got
Steve Smith similar type of thing where
you just go man they're built with a
little more muscular density than the
normal wide receiver and he pops on film
he really does
he is a not a not a like jaw-dropping
route runner yet he's still a little raw
from that standpoint but man his ability
to scare people and he's not even
running at full speed yet is what's
really amazing about him ability to
scare people right ability like he can
go he can come out of the box and he's
not really going but he's moving pretty
good he hasn't really turned it on to
that sixth gear yet and he still scares
DB's to go oh gosh she's gonna run by me
let me go but the thing that I looked at
he was an open a number of times where
they missed him or didn't have
protection whatever it may be
he had one double move where Garret
Gilbert actually threw a touchdown to
the right side but he ran a little like
stop go on the left side and the guy
didn't really bite on it he stopped for
a second but he was like five yards off
but just like the draft his ability to
stop and restart and get the full speed
is as good as anybody in the sport like
an Odell Beckham jr. to where he made
the double move the guy paused five
yards down the field he exploded and he
ran past that guy to Gharib Gilbert had
thrown it to him back in the end zone he
was an outrun the guy and scored the
touchdown but then the other thing I
just looked at is his physicality and
his ability to not only make explosive
quick moves with the ball on his hand
but he can break arm tackles because of
that lower body strength and he he had
the thing he has to work on is he has
tremendous urgency with his body when
the balls in his hand he has to be like
that when it's not in his hand because
he can catch a comeback and you go damn
he wasn't even really turning it on
there and he got the comeback but as
soon as he got in the ball to saying it
was like dude like you gotta learn to
run routes like that too cuz they're
just gonna make him that much better but
I'm very impressed and I would have
a hard time thinking he's not gonna be
the go-to guy or that he starts because
Torrey Smith is the guy that they're
starting there right now and I would
just say as long as DJ more catches up
on the mental aspect that's not a
contest do you think he could have a big
year this year yeah I do I did right
away I really do I mean he went up and
caught a 50/50 ball quarterback got his
he was throwing it you know he's got the
tremendous of catching 50/50 balls it's
his body control is off the charts yes
he could be one of those guys in that
offense where you know I know they don't
throw it a ton but I think he can have a
lot of big plays and he can probably
inject himself into the Rookie of the
Year conversation on offense yeah I do
I think he's that special an athlete two
guys that will definitely not be in the
rookie there discussion because they are
offensive linemen yeah but there's no
really way quantify it right you you
said you wanted to talk about two
rookies on the Indianapolis offensive
line yeah I think so I mean the thing
that I think jumps out to me about the
Indianapolis Colts first of all is their
offensive line when you really look at
you go they have a chance to be
something special you take Brian Kelly
Center out of Alabama example said was
the best center in that draft right then
they flanked him with our man hey
Quentin Quentin Nelson exactly and
Braden Smith a guard from where he's the
guard from Auburn Auburn so if you guys
remember if you go and look at YouTube
from our draft content there was a guy
that started off the second round
Austin Corbett went to Cleveland Simms
was freaking out because there were two
guys that you thought were better than
him yeah significantly one was Braden
Smith Rhys now on the Colts and it's him
and quit Nelson together and the other
was will Hernandez the guy that went to
the Giant exactly right so I don't think
a lot of people know about Braden Smith
yeah what did the Colts have in Nelson
and Smith yeah I mean Nelson was really
good in the game he wasn't perfect he
got beat a few times in pass bro because
against the seal against the Seahawks he
got beat a few times because it's the
NFL and he's never had some guys like
that put some of these moves on him he's
not used to it
he wasn't like out of position or
overpowered but he got fooled by like
hand fighting where he went in to lean
in and the guy did give him like the old
tap and he was gone like that to that
top that goes out there I'm not sure if
I like that one more that's not even
using the sound board so he's great he
got beat like that a little bit where
that's just like he's just gotta get
used to it
Arians pass rushers than guys that have
more than two moves than in college
football right so he's gonna be a stud
he was great I saw one pole yeah leveled
on the right side there yeah pulled out
from the left to the right side yes so
but I have no worries about Quentin
Nelson Braden Smith he wasn't with the
starting group he played guard in the
game
I honestly think after watching the game
and I know today that they talked about
they're gonna play him and let him have
a chance to start at right tackle I
think he's gonna be better at right time
right tackle yes I think he's gonna be
better at right tackle I don't know if
he has enough ass to hunker in there
against some of the just big giant d
tackle especially because right tackle
has become in a weird way the new left a
little bit I mean you definitely have to
have the he has the footwork the length
and I do think he might be better at a
right tackle altogether but I would just
say he's a guy to watch out for throw
the austin howard denzel good Joe Haeg
is sort of like all the guys at right
tackle right right and Jamarcus Webb
actually started the game at right
tackle in a game and I mean Jamarcus
Webb's a journeyman good but just even
that that's good depth and Raven Clark
they took like G stands o at left tackle
Nelson at left guard Kelly at Center
Slauson at right guard and then you put
a whatever it is Austin Howard or this
kid Braden Smith I look at that line and
go you can't just think it's gonna be
Andrew Luck throwing it 40 times this
year you better watch out it really
reminds me of the Eagles offensive line
last year where they had this year where
they before the year had lost Jason
Peters was messed up and Lane Johnson
didn't play ten games and everyone was
going where's the depth but because all
the backups had to get a full year of
reps now they're made a lot better and I
look at the Colts and I go I have been
saying all offseason I think the Colts
might be the surprise team yeah that
could be I just literally don't I I
don't think people realize that this
team that was awful last year right was
leading going into the fourth quarter in
9 of the 16 games no it's amazing you're
right and you kind of look at it and go
man if Andrew Luck is what we think
Andrew Luck can be right look out for
the Colt I mean their defense stinks
yeah there's some names on the defense I
don't think it's gonna be as bad as I
thought but it's not a lot of big
difference makers alright so let's go to
defense let's talk about that same game
right yes yes regime green yeah let's
just talk about regime green real USC
product 94 on 94 I've seen them in
person when no
in us he played each other so I know
what kind of body the guy the guy is a
big strong densely muscular dude right
they played three four at USC so he
basically had to play a position that he
wouldn't play in the NFL he was to gap
in offensive tackles but he's got
tremendous strength for his size you
know six for 275 he was a third round
yeah I mean he's jacked it's a 275 where
it's just muscle and bone that's all
there is to the guy and I just look at
him and when I mean first of all he is
he's legit he's gonna be their starting
defense to end and Seattle really and he
can do a lot of different things along
that defense line I think he can be that
Michael Bennett type guy that plays
defense and D tackle and I'm kind of
going instead of Nazr Jones alongside
chair and Reed yes I think so
and I just think when I look at him he
really reminds me of our guy in New
Orleans
I think he could be that cam Jordan I do
that's a high pride and I'm just saying
but he's bought his movements and his
style of play that's who he reminds me
of not saying he's there yet but I do
think he can be that kind of guy he's
got the potential to do that interesting
yeah cam Jordan is 6 for 287 there we go
pretty close and I Wow is a big play I
know he's got he's he's he's special I
think he was under drafted because he
was out of position in college and some
idiots in the league just can't evaluate
and figure it out all right so keep an
eye out for regime green yeah another D
lineman did not play for Washington but
you're hearing some things
yeah Doron painter on pain which was the
first think it was one of the first
surprise picks in the draft just because
a lot of people were mocking him towards
the end of the first right and he went
in the middle of the first to Washington
right Alabama mover Alabama Missouri
what are you here in an Alabama
you can't just evaluate the film you got
to go oh it's Alabama he's not allowed
to just put his ears back and go he has
to hold his ground and to gap you have
to be able to evaluate that and when you
see him getting a four down front you
could see some of those things they go
oh okay I get it
what did I who do I compare and it'll
coming on the draft come on short I
believe is who I can compare to I had a
little birdie tell me that he was
opening eyes in DC so then I text some
of my friends in DC and yeah I think
he's been one of the Wow's of the camp
to this point
yes I mean he is a guy like I said
really can do everything in the interior
part of the defensive line but he has a
special ability like our favorite
players that he could be a [ __ ] the play
up type of guy and beyond the stats I
has that for swears name II know you're
gay okay you've been selective okay good
but yes that kind of line they they do
play like a three-four in washing like
at three four hybrid right that's what
you call a three four under front it's
like a four three front with some three
four characteristics but if Jonathan
Allen can stay healthy I think he was
playing pretty well then you have to run
pain and then you're mixing in the
Preston Smiths and and some of the other
guys up front yes
it's not bad it's not bad they got they
got a chance this year they really do
alright so you you're hearing really I'm
really good I'm impressed
like been the star of the camp on
defenses out of the ball yeah right all
right right that was a good thing he was
the 13th overall pick I think a lot of
people were expecting them to go in a
lot of different ways but he end up
going 13 next one
Tremayne Edmonds mm-hmm linebacker for
the bills yeah
Jermaine Edmonds was we thought could go
as high as sick right and he fell down
to the teens yes man he's a freak show
athletically even in the ops right pops
right away you know it's it's the
Buffalo defense which is the Carolina
defense he's gonna be asked to do like
what Luke Kuechly does and all that
first thing is he starts Game one you
can tell he's directing traffic he's
completely comfortable a little
undisciplined a little because he's very
quick to read and react he really is so
much to the point a per at the snap like
he's very good at like oh the ball is
going here I'm gonna try to beat him
there he might actually have to slow
down a little bit because like they
bootleg and do things like that and he's
already over there by them running back
and the quarterback is over there and he
can't get in the play or even you know
guessing in a hole where they're running
back Mike go-to and they're running back
cut it up in another hole and you want
to go damn if you just were a little
slower to react you've been there but
yes like what I saw I mean can fly
around the field you know can take on
guards at the point of attack and really
I just think his true beauty of the
player is gonna come out through the
regular season because it's gonna be
past defenses where he's really gonna
make his mark Bray
those guys trying to throw over the
middle of a field he is gonna scare a
lot of people from doing that because of
his physicality lengthen just his
presence alone so I know how you watch
Phil yeah so you're watching I'm sure
you're looking out for what was kind of
your initial reactions as just look at
him in the uniform yeah the first thing
is like oh 49 that's him yeah I didn't
have to look it up cuz again there's no
linebackers that look like this in the
sport and then the first thing was just
let me watch him run I mean he just
stands out he's running by the other
linebackers when he's running into the
football whatever it may be but yet the
first impression of him right there is
wow he belongs and wow he looks pretty
special at that position already like I
said it's not perfect he's a little raw
but it's it's a good start one guy that
you were super high on in all the
cornerbacks you know there was the
battle at the top of denzel awards and
the gyre Alexander's and Josh Jackson
was being mentioned but you were one of
the first ones to go we need to talk
about this UCF kid yeah Mike Hughes
and we talked about it last podcast all
the talk right now to Minnesota the
special team guy going he is special
the defensive coordinator going he
showed a lot of flashes what did you see
do you feel confirmed you feel
vindicated
I'm confirmed I am I mean just the way I
saw in week one he's got a great
presence on the field which is what
concerns me about Denzel Ward was why I
didn't like him we'll get to that in a
second but Hughes is he's lightning in a
bottle he just he's in your face he
didn't start he came in with the second
nickel right when he got in and first of
all Minnesota are so stacked in their
second it's ridiculous I mean it's
ridiculous i mean it's it's xavier and
then it's trey wanes and then it's
Alexander McKenzie coming in and see
Alexander Nichol McKenzie Alexander
right Terrance Newman just chosen was
just chilling oh and then no here Marcus
Cheryl's exactly right and then and then
here comes you know our man number 21 I
think is too is look at their safeties
Harrison Smith I enter Sunday ho
J Ron curse I know was like a super
athlete yeah and then also Anthony
Harris is a really good player that gets
in on the road at about their secondary
it's real I don't know how they're gonna
keep everybody I don't know either I
mean but this this kid his his
explosiveness
you're watching the film and you find
him yes he has first of all the body I
like it's just right away his body is oh
there he is yep that looks like him yeah
oh yeah I mean so twitchy
but his exploring his ability to explode
like the play you originally sent me
last week yes running down the line of
scrimmage right making the tackle of the
opposite side on the run game he can get
up to full speed in two two steps but
also his ability and man demand a mirror
and okay stay on a guy's hip oh the guys
exploding I can explode with him always
stopping I can stop with him on a dime
that's where I just think it's special
and yeah I think he's got a chance I
wouldn't be shocked if he's the starter
when all said and done there I really
wouldn't I think he's gonna be a Trey
Wayne yeah I think he's a better player
than trae Waynes at the true essence of
the player and I think he's got better
ball skills and tradewinds which has
been an issue for Trey so you actually
looked at Mike Hughes and went oh I
could see it being a Xavier Rhoads Mike
Hughes tandem and Trey Wayne's get spun
do you think they think that - I I think
it's definitely in their brain yes the
way he put they played him as far as he
got in there with the starters and got
to be a nickel and then you know be the
second group of starting corners and all
that yes and Zimmer's the kind of guy -
that usually pumps his brakes on those
guys and really miss him earn their
stripes so for him to have that role
that early on tells me he's impressed
man you know soda I know I'm sorry I
think I think people kind of sleep on
him a little bit yeah I know I might
pick them it's tough that division i
dial it junior Alexander isn't playing
yet so hopefully he plays Thursday night
but there were two safeties in this
draft yeah that were expected to go high
right and both did Derwin a little bit
lower than make a fitzpatrick right
let's let's talk about them in draft
order Thank You Fitzpatrick right safety
goes to Miami when they drafted him
everyone talked about how he was gonna
kind of play a little bit of everything
maybe he's gonna play some corner he
could play some nickel it could play
some safety yeah they love the
versatility and we know that he's just a
great kid yeah how did he look in the
uniform starts right about the starting
11 defense minka Fitzpatrick's the
starting safety what do you think about
in the uniform looks great looks just
like he did in Alabama wearing 29 got
great ass and legs first play of the
game he's covering the slot receiver
man-to-man across the field he's all
over him
that's such a value to have he's he
belongs she when you play the Patriots
twice a year yeah he belongs man I don't
know what else to say other than that he
broke up a past a good one
Godwin I was messy Godwin and I'm the
Bucks than the last gun cover to shot
and mink it was a little slow to read it
but his ability to go from 0 to 60 and
three steps is very impressive as well
you know whether he's down there
covering the slot and he scares you to
throw bubble screens cuz he's so quick
to explode but the most impressive thing
to not a little the physical ability is
special and they made a great pick he's
he he's directing the defense already I
mean this is like between play I mean
he's I look for those things before the
ball snapped and he's pointing people
and he's telling the corner to back off
and he's got it already and what's what
all you heard this is why Nick Saban's
sang his praise so yeah they hit a gem
there he's gonna he's starting day one
how much can someone at that position
impact a defense overall a lot
I think safety is a very impactful
position because of the mental aspect
the physical aspect we saw with a Jets
last yeah that's what I mean you have a
badass back right we can communicate get
the defense oh wait coach said he didn't
like one word we get in this coverage
and they motion to that formation you
know we audible audible he'll sound
other signals I get out of this all
those save coaches from bad plays that
saves your team from letting up seven
points sometimes I'm something every
safety exactly especially on the fly and
especially in a rookie so I was gonna
say the guy this benefits the most is
Rashad Jones yes without a shot John's
has always been a super physical up at
the line safety but because they've
always been bad at that position he's
had to be the one in the back right
I think we're shot is he could get a
blur because of McCafe sure no down then
the guy that fell that we I mean
everybody was so entranced by with his
physical attributes
Derwin James yeah Los Angeles chargers I
don't know what did you think I was a
little underwhelmed Derwin has my only
concern about Derwin in the draft I
don't know if you remember this I do
was his short area quickness he thought
he was a little bit big he's a long
Strider and he didn't start he came in
you know somewhere I'm gonna say half
way
maybe early second quarter when he
finally got into play the safety
position and he didn't do much I'm not
gonna say he looked bad but he looked
like he was a little lost a few times
let up a completion with rosin through
like an in cut behind him in one point
he was a little late to pick up the
route ray the guy beat him at the back
door
you know again it wasn't bad I'm not
gonna sit here and judge any of this to
critically but he didn't pop like Minka
did and that's gonna be my concern with
him and this is some of the concerns I
had with them like cuz I love the guy
and I love how he hits and I love his
attitude and all that but I did worry
about his ability to be against the
quicker Jitterbug guys in that area of
the field his straight ahead straight
ahead speeds good but it takes him a few
steps to get up to it and sometimes that
can be like kam chancellor he stretched
his his straight ahead speed is not that
good but he could get to his top-end
speed in like a half a step so that made
up for it if that position sometimes
that short area quickness in my opinion
is just as important is oh we ran a four
for 800 camp chance arena for six I
don't give a damn in those first 10
yards he's as fast as the guy that ran
the 4 for 8 and that's what's important
at times hmm so that's where I'll just
be looking at him how did he look at the
jersey he looks cool wearing 33 yeah he
looks the part
he really does he's long and lanky so
you found yourself kind of looking at
him and being like okay I have some
concerns yeah just yeah I go see more at
this point it's just something you're
gonna pay yeah just gonna pay I'm not
concerned just I just want to pay
attention right alright yeah so it
sounds like to me that DJ Moore and Mike
Hughes you're looking at and going those
two could really be special I feel
validated on that right you're looking
at the offensive lineman for the Colts
and going okay yeah you know I don't
underestimate group regime green you
felt very confident yeah I mean just
because I was watching the Colts online
Google Cole C was Andrew Luck playing
he's starting over there yeah he's like
I didn't mean to watch a third rounder
but when you know the third rounder gets
the sack and a half and is pushing
people back into the face of the
quarterback it's hard not to pay
attention to him yeah
so that's kind of how you look at
preseason games
yes preseason week one we're looking to
kind of see who looks good in New Jersey
who looks like they belong there people
like minka can blow you away in terms of
how
quickly they're picking it up right
that's the reason you draft make if it's
Patrick at number la exactly right and
then week two how are you gonna approach
watching week to week to I'm still gonna
do more than anything just evaluate the
players like that's all I want to do at
this point but I will at least this week
take notice of scheme a little
especially when the starters are in cuz
I might go uh okay scheme I want to
check this out see what they're doing
it's a different formation you know
especially with new coaches like we did
with the Giants and patch Shermer last
week we saw things like that but your
hats defense looking great yeah exactly
alright so let me get I put that well no
because I totally ignored you I did not
ignore you well I have to get to the the
questions did you want to get to some of
those uh what questions do you want that
I had put on Instagram I was reaching
out to people oh you're some teacher I
forget how to access the questions you
forget how to access the question yeah
when I put a thing up when you put a
thing I put that thing up hello oh you
gotta click the view count in the bottom
okay yeah there is I say what are you
talking about and then if the questions
are supposed to pop up yeah they okay so
I have a few questions from our
instagram at citizen love co which i
think is a good way to kind of get that
this one's from rod Simba what team
could successfully run a two quarterback
system in the NFL what conditions are
needed to make it work okay I don't know
if there's any conditions that can make
it work rod to beetroot like totally
honest with you because I just feel like
whenever you run a two quarterback
system I do think you're dividing the
football team there's gonna be some guys
that are in one camp and some guys that
are in the other camp know you can do it
maybe the along the ways of like how
Neil o'donald and Kordell Stewart did it
back in the day a little bit where maybe
we'll see that from Flacco and Lamar
Jackson this year where you just come in
he's got a few gadget plays every game
where he can line up but to say that
you're totally gonna it's gonna split
quarterbacks up and you know I don't
know depend on both of them I just don't
think that's realistic in the NFL it's
hard to get the quarterback to the reps
they won and I think the biggest thing
like I said is you're gonna divide the
locker room you know it's like we talked
about with a
Cleveland Browns well maybe they should
pick a quarterback with the first and
fourth pick increase the rods yeah okay
that'll be the first way to become a
dysfunctional organization so I just
think that's the reason you don't see it
it's the reason we don't see a lot of
talented backups anymore in the league
because coaches are so scared of their
starter feeling threatened which i think
is stupid and we're seeing that you know
competition usually breeds greatness
eyes were seen like Joe Flacco looks
like a new guy why because he's got two
guys behind him that are physically good
and scare the [ __ ] out of him a little
Jordan Colvin did Sims ever play with or
against a cockier player than Jalen
Ramsay Oh mmm cockier player than Jalen
Ramsay I don't think so because like you
know I mean Ray and Ed Reed and Julius
Peppers they certainly had amazing
confidence but not like this not like
this no I mean D'Angelo was confident as
hell certainly but no this is another
level right here I can't think of
anybody done naming people yeah that I
could just say like yeah this is this is
a special event I think I mean this is
you don't see this every day
Chetta says Eagles fan till I die not a
question just wanted Adam to know thank
you
jazzy we're a Pittsburgh shirt today
Janice heard I says what's the status on
left goes legs and ass fly eagles fly
from Denmark so they're pretty good I
mean I need haven't seen left cone naked
yet we'll get there at some point gotta
see him in some I need to put left going
some tight span because they say we
should put him in a football uniform and
he's left goes got he's got nice thighs
certainly does his booty you know it's
kind of just a big square white person's
booty there's not a lot of bubble in
there but if there's ISA bubble tricky
one for left goes Alex Weber if you
could only keep one Fletcher Cox or
Carson Wentz what would you take Carson
Wentz are you gonna you're gonna go
think about this I mean it depends if
we're talking like year and year or like
for the rest of the career rest of the
career I'm taking I'm taking Carson
Wentz right but just this year sure I
can make an argument for Fletcher Cox I
got Nick Foles for one year look I
watched the first that first drive of
the first two drives really the eagle
Steelers I want to tell you that there
was nobody more impressive on either
side of the ball than Fletcher Cox yeah
like the the Steelers offense couldn't
function
Fletcher Cox Brooklyn ruined three plays
David the cache in the only guy he can't
block in football it's Fletcher Cox I
mean like blocks everybody except for
that guy Fletcher Cox to me is a top 10
player in the NFL I mean the fact that
he was ranked 69 by the you know Sims
jay-z amaura 1017 what is your favorite
uniform in the NFL oh these questions
Lecky okay I'm an old-school guy I do I
will say that they're all out of all the
new age uniforms there's only one I like
and that's Seattle it's the only you
just told me you like tennis seasoning
if you like the look of it I haven't let
it like I got a little breathing you got
a pick what about the team you told us
about in the car in LA
remember no well you can tell me NFC's
team well the Redskins the NFC's
uniforms are phenomenal yeah I mean
they're traditional classic I think the
Eagles actually have the worst uniform
in the division I'm sorry but okay hold
on just give me a second I'm a sucker
for the Dallas Cowboys Thanksgiving one
with the shoulders
yeah it just reminds me the movie Little
Giants yeah and it's both the team's
pick one I know I got an arrow down so
just hear me through it out I mean
Dallas is certainly one of them I think
that the Raiders are another one I
probably would go like Cleveland without
the stripe yeah but I'm not gonna put
them in there some of the Steelers the
Bears
I know those you everybody's doing like
oh you're so boring yeah you like the
traditional I do I like I think if you
made me pick one I'm going with the
Raiders you like Penn State's ecology
reforms they're okay yes I do I like the
simpleness of Penn State's uniform yes I
love you must hate Oregon Oh get the
hell out of here yes Neverland no oh
well I don't even know what's going on
in that uniform they got more designs
going on yeah I love the Michigan normal
Michigan I hate when Ohio State wears
those crazy uniforms when they play
Michigan you got one of the greatest
uniforms there is don't mess with that
I mean yes so I think that's it I think
I'm the Raiders yeah this is an
interesting football question TBG 709
what's holding Jonathan Hankins back
from signing he's the best would rush
defender available yeah yeah I know I
don't know what it is I don't know if
he's looking for the right deal whatever
it is he didn't have a great year last
year it wasn't bad but it wasn't great
um I really I can't I can't have an
answer for you there I don't know I
really is it because he's like a two
down guy and I just could be part of it
yes I got a is there something out there
on the street that I don't know about
when I read the articles about him the
other day I did think like I need to
call some people and kind of hear the
story about this guy quote from Giants
came today Eli was asked about Jalen
Ramsey's interview with GQ Manning said
no comment then paused and said Who oh
good free life
that's great Eli is a lot funnier than I
thought he was he is King George asks
who will be the best rookie quarterback
this season hmm if you had to pick one
of them yeah I think I'm gonna go with
Sam it's a little overreacting no I
don't think it's a week one of the
preseason I don't think yeah of course
it's all overreacting but I feel like
Sam is the only one right now where I
can go he's definitely gonna start week
one like I think Sam darn 'old is gonna
be the week one starter you know Baker I
don't think we're gonna see for a while
Josh Allen he is raw I don't know if
he's charged right away and he is
probably the least amount of help around
him yeah I'm on with Sam darling I'm
joining that club there big guy are you
picking Josh I'll go Sam Donald - good
job Josh I'm running out of gas here
since 3:00 in the morning as well yeah
all right show time burn show time burn
says has anyone ever told you that you
and Seth Rogen have quite similar voices
yes we've heard that before is that true
do I sound like Seth Rogen do I sound
like that I don't think I feel
acceptable talks were gross I feel like
he's like inside of a submarine yeah a
little bit we have a line from when he
gets you know the girl pregnant we're
inhib-a-line and have you talked to it
Seth Rogen quote all right so here's I'm
just gonna click on
here we go girl doesn't want to end the
podcast today I don't know okay stop
it's dr. Seuss's Pete do I sound like
yeah you're kind of close it's close
it's similar he we really needed to get
a profile shot of you and Jared Goff
together while we were in Rams camp we
screwed up not getting that well I don't
think Jared Goff was kind of stuff for
him no he was not gonna come hang no
yeah I think we were all I think we were
all just mesmerized the stink-eye that
he gave the crest he definitely did he
was not pleased and then what you guys
are informed me that people show he's I
guess admitted that like people show him
bleacher report alert supported saying
there's a lot of rams people are coming
up to us be like oh yeah you talked to
like you were getting called out by the
rain so they're mad at me because I just
last year remember when the whole thing
is McVeigh was talking in his ear when
they would break the huddle yeah I
didn't like that he said it was unfair I
think it's unfair I think Sean McVeigh
would probably agree with you I think he
would I think you would he probably
coach in the NFL Sean McVeigh podcast I
think I think I'm gonna be a show
McVeigh family as well yes football pure
so it wasn't a shot they're not the only
team that does that I'm not it was just
I don't like it that's awesome alright
guys thank you so much you guys have
been awesome
as always follow us on social at Sims
and Lefko we are getting closer to the
Sims and left go fantasy league drafts
so get excited get prepared we're gonna
come with our teenage Golden League
League we're gonna be the Otto Rogers
thing that comes yeah great job Sims and
then if you signed up for the [ __ ] to
play up I'm sure that Tim will be
organizing that so you guys are great
man we're getting close so excited are
after week threes when we were gonna do
our division winners or Super Bowl
winners and our big bets get some left
go locks in there for Sims peace out
homies forfend Rick good evening
everybody and for the lef koe man we
will ha alright guys be well talk to you
soon